finally some good news for president
Trump you know it's about time you get
some good news yeah
president Trump is actually getting a
lot of praise for his response to
hurricanes Harvey and Irma he's getting
some praise yeah oh come on yeah here's
the thing though you know it's not a
good sign for your presidency when the
best things that happened to you is two
hurricanes that's it that's the only
problem that's the flip side he's
probably watching The Weather Channel
let's get another one in here tonight
this is interesting tonight President
Trump is hosting Democratic leaders
Nancy Pelosi and Chuck Schumer at the
White House for dinner they might be
coming together of course Pelosi and
Schumer may want to be careful because
Trump's wine steward is Arya Stark
I acted the whole thing out for
everybody I did for really no reason at
all every noon anyone go out and buy a
Hillary Clinton's book yet
okay good save everyone's talking about
it she has some pretty interesting
revelations in that book Hillary Clinton
in her book said that after Trump's
inauguration speech george w bush told
her that was some weird [ __ ]
[Music]
yeah it's being called the most eloquent
statement ever made by george w bush
they should be I can't believe he said
that they're gonna carve that into his
library yeah that was some weird [ __ ] I
love him for saying that a few days
after being accused of liking a porn
tweet on Twitter senator Ted Cruz
dismissed the claim saying the left is
obsessed with sex yeah Cruz Cruz then
said and if they want to call me I can
recommend some great websites I'm
working on my cruise I can show you some
weird [ __ ] yeah that's my cruise he's
got that weird yeah it's like sad about
something he's sad yeah first area
Apple Apple is working with medical
professionals to see if Apple watches
can detect heart problems yeah here's
here's how it works if the Apple watch
doesn't fit around your wrist you have a
heart problem
you're buttering your arm that's not a
good sign this is crazy in a sewer in
London all right follow me on this not
down the sewer but follow me on the
story in a sewer in the London officials
found a giant clump of fat waste and
diapers known as fatberg it's massive
its massive yeah the fat burger is so
repulsive officials are divided on
whether to dissolve it or cast it as a
dance mom they don't know which way to
go
it's a guy here to cap booing me he's
you're in the second row dude and he was
like no this show is free man all right
you get what you say no leave the Dance
Moms alone
in Palm Springs California a Starbucks
barista saved the customers life by
giving him CPR
apparently the customer had a heart
attack when the barista spelled his name
right so
you
you